markets changed a lot particularly from
like the technology that's available to
people I remember back in 2016 you know
this this concept of even meeting people
online was super alien never mind
recording that interaction right it's
like I can't remember the last time I
was on an online meeting where it wasn't
automatically recorded whether that's
internally or externally you know back
then that was almost quite I wouldn't
say revolutionary but definitely a very
new idea and A New Concept I think a lot
of the tech that existed back kind of
2016 2017 was coming more so from like
the in-house side of things so a lot
like job War technology search and match
you know a lot of that kind of candidate
work where is what I see a lot more now
is tools that Focus also on the business
development side of things got a big
focus on recruiter efficiency and
automation as well but I think like
automation eii efficiency or an approach
to a more efficient process is something
that's become more of a focus for
recruitment businesses naturally over
time